скажи чесно як ти Я тримаюсь я тримаюсь
чесно та якщо накриваєте накриває сильно
останній раз Це була історія з собакою
Крим мене ця історія дуже тоді торкнули
я просто сиджу і плачу
постав ноги на ширину пліч плавно
підніми праву руку вгору тягнися ребром
правої долоні догори ніби пробуєш
тиснути ним на небо а ребром лівої руки
тягнися донизу такий позі зробив кілька
плавних вдихів і видихів Уяви що ти
дерево яке повільно розхитує ніжний
вітер трішки погойдається на вдиху
плавно вийде спози і поклади долоні на
груди на видих у повільно їх опустив
перепочинь кілька секунд і зробити те
саме але вже з іншою рукою
додай цю техніку в свою аптечку
самодопомоги більше тут